[Music]
on this saturday night
paying civil servants to stay home
taxpayers are on the hook for hundreds
of millions in paid leave to government
employees
who claimed they couldn't work during
the covid19 lockdown
we should not be in a situation where
there's one class of workers that works
for the government
and then there's everyone else pandemic
pub protest
hundreds of bars in texas reopen defying
a state order
plus here comes hannah the first
hurricane of the season
bears down on the southern united states
and he wants to be a millionaire
saying goodbye to a tv legend
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple good evening and thank you
for joining us the covet 19 pandemic has
forced millions of canadians to work
from home
and it hasn't always been easy many
struggling to juggle child care
and adjust to new ways of working but a
new report from canada's budget watchdog
is raising eyebrows
it's revealed that scores of civil
servants were being paid to stay home
during the pandemic
without having to work michael couture
has been digging
into this report for us and joins us now
from our ottawa bureau with the details
mike jeff when unionized federal civil
servants can't report for work for
reasons beyond their control
such as the covet 19 pandemic they can
use a special leave known for its pay
code
699 now the pandemic prevented a lot of
people from being able to work for a
variety of reasons
and it's estimated that cost the
government more than
half a billion dollars in lost
productivity
the report from the country's budget
watchdog shows between march 15th
and may 31st of this year more than 76
thousand public servants
took some kind of paid leave and because
not all departments supplied numbers
the total cost could be between 439
and 623 million dollars
seventy percent of that went to the
canada revenue agency
it had the highest number of employees
were granted
a 699 leave their union says one of the
reasons
is because they didn't have access to
proper secure technology
to do their jobs in some cases yes i
mean there had to be firewalls
established in that and as i said for
the protection
of of people's information the canadian
taxpayers federation says this special
leave creates two tiers of workers in
this country
as a pbo rightly knows there's no
similar thing available
anywhere in the private sector and we
should not be in a situation where
there's one class of workers that works
for the government
and then there's everyone else another
union president disagrees
pointing to the cerb and wage subsidy
programs the federal government has
promised
82.6 billion for private sector help
so the 439 billion seems like a drop in
the bucket competitively speaking
the pbo report noted fewer employees
used that leave as the weeks wore
on in the pandemic a spokesperson for
treasury board president
xiv duklow said in a statement as
expected
we are now seeing a dramatic decline in
the use of this leave
as more regular government and private
sector services
and operations are restored one
government source told global news on
average employees took
50 hours of paid leave during the
pandemic so if you do the math that's
just over a week of work
lost during a pandemic that is
stretching into its fifth
month jeff michael couture reporting
from ottawa thanks mike
well hundreds gathered in toronto this
afternoon to honor the life of regis
korchinsky paquette
her family held a memorial and walk for
justice outside the apartment building
where she fell to her death nearly two
months ago
police say they were called to her home
back on may 27 for a possible assault
but her mother says she wanted officers
to take her daughter to a mental health
facility
ontario's police watchdog is now
investigating the 29-year-old's death
its findings are expected as early as
next month
and korchinsky paquette's death is also
renewing calls for police body cameras
officers in toronto like most others
across the country do not wear the
controversial cameras
global news has learned quebec
provincial police purchased more than
200 cameras a few years ago
but not a single one has been used dan
spector
explains why somewhere in the hulking
headquarters of the circe de quebec
dozens of body cameras that could be
recording police interactions with the
public
have been collecting dust for three
years sq
officers want to use them according to
their union president
we've been asking the employer to
conduct a pilot project for a few years
now says
this contract document obtained by
global news shows that in 2017
the sq bought 169 body cameras
33 dashboard cameras and cloud space to
store the videos
for 560 thousand dollars they even
created a training program for
officers with the goal of launching a
pilot project
but it never happened why the union
claims quebec's crown
prosecutors are to blame for the unused
cameras
for them it's a major problem he told
global news vegas said crown prosecutors
are concerned about having the manpower
and the equipment necessary to view
manage and bring body camera evidence to
court
it would considerably increase their
workload so for them
it was hard to accept veya explained
but in calgary every frontline police
officer has been equipped with a body
camera for over a year now
how did crown prosecutors make it work
there it certainly required additional
resources
jonathan hack was an alberta crown
prosecutor for more than 30 years
when he left in 2018 body cameras were
beginning to be implemented in calgary
it would be a shame for any prosecution
service to say no we would rather not
have this potentially valuable evidence
because we don't have the capacity to
process it montreal defense lawyer
phillip schneider says quebec
prosecutors have no trouble using
other types of video evidence we have
the technology to bring to court
uh social media evidence of people
filming things with their cell phones we
have the technology to bring to court
the evidence of surveillance cameras i'm
sure the technology exists to bring this
to court too the quebec crown
prosecutor's office refused to comment
on veya's claims telling global news
only that they had provided a legal
opinion on body cameras to the sq
leaving any decision up to the police
force they would not tell us what was
in the legal opinion when we filed an
access to information request to get it
a request was denied
hopes widespread demands for greater
police accountability pushed the sq to
finally start the pilot project by the
end of the year
dan spector global news montreal
ceremonies are now underway in alabama
to honor the life of civil rights hero
and congressman
john lewis this community is honored
that you're here
and we mourn and grieve with you and
pray for you thank you very much
speaking at the funeral the mayor of his
hometown noted the irony of alabama
state troopers carrying the casket
troopers brutally beat lewis back in
1965 during a civil rights march
on edmond pettis bridge his casket will
now be carried over that same bridge in
selma as part of a week-long procession
spanning five cities
lewis passed away last week after a
six-month battle with cancer
he was 80. well turning now to the
pandemic covid19 cases are soaring
across the united states
there are now more than 4 million
confirmed infections and the u.s is
nearing a grim milestone as more than
146
000 americans have died florida is one
of the hardest hit areas in the country
on average a person is dying from the
virus in that state every 11 minutes
as jennifer johnson explains the surge
in cases is forcing many states to bring
back restrictions hundreds of bar owners
in texas
reopened their doors saturday in
protests of governor greg abbott's
shutdown order
the owners are fed up with losing so
much revenue as cases and deaths from
covent 19 continue to rise in their
state
our customers need us my employees need
us
our owners need us and
this is too good to let go abbott is now
considering locking down texas again
hospitals in houston and those near the
mexico border are struggling to keep up
with the constant
and growing flow of covet-19 cases and
hospitalizations
texas florida and california are now
considered three new yorks
by white house coronavirus doctors as
outbreaks surge
but cases are rising in other states too
new rules in nashville
are banning party buses
although some apparently didn't know it
yet many residents want more
restrictions
we're like a dog chasing the tail we're
not getting nowhere
the u.s department of health and human
services is processing almost eight
hundred thousand
covet 19 tests a day but results are
taking up to two weeks to get back
with many people struggling to
quarantine while they wait
they're asking people to stay in not do
anything not be around
anybody else and put your life on hold
the national institutes of health is
spending 1.5 billion dollars on
developing a rapid test
like the rapid strep test but there's no
timetable yet on when it will be
available to the public
none of us are going to be happy until
that's under 48 hours
but we're making all our efforts to do
that this weekend florida opened up five
additional federal testing sites to get
more people screened
as that state and others try to get a
handle on this relentless pandemic
jennifer johnson global news washington
in texas the governor is contending with
the impact of covid 19 as the state
faces
another threat hurricane hannah the
first hurricane of the season is now
bearing down on the state's southern
coast
hannah a category one storm made
landfall with sustained winds of 150
kilometers an hour with even
stronger gusts hurricane warnings are
now in effect and flooding is also a
major concern
from a storm surge that could bring more
than a meter of water ashore
governor greg abbott is urging people in
the storm's path to stay safe but also
to stay physically
distant from one another for those
unable to remain in their homes
temporary shelters will be set up
with extra effort to sanitize the
facilities and stop the spread of
covid19
among those people needing a safe place
to stay
breaking news in the entertainment world
tonight american tv legend
regis philbin has passed away at the age
of 88.
philbin entered show business back in
the 1950s rising to fame as the host and
namesake of his morning
show he was also the host of the game
show who wants to be a millionaire
philbin won five daytime emmys including
a lifetime achievement award
laura podesta looks back at his life and
legacy
regis philbin was one of the most
familiar entertainers on television
he's said to have logged more hours in
front of the camera than anyone else in
the history of the medium
in more recent years philbin was the
first host of the very popular tv game
show who wants to be a millionaire
which tested contestants knowledge of
trivia i'm going to make it your final
answer i'm going to do that
[Music]
you're right for 23 years he served as
co-host on live with regis
and kathy lee and later live with regis
and kelly when kelly ripa replaced
kathie lee gifford
the bronx new york native was always
prepared with a story
joke and a smile he appeared as a guest
on countless other shows including on
cbs's late show after david letterman
announced his retirement
but now you're leaving yeah that's right
so where does that leave regions i don't
care
where am i going to go i don't know in a
statement philbin's family said we thank
his fans and admirers for their
incredible support over his 60-year
career
and ask for privacy as we mourn his loss
regis philbin was 88 years old laura
podesta cbs
news new york and the music world is
also mourning the loss of one of its
greatest guitarists
peter green the blues rock legend and
co-founder of fleetwood mac one of the
biggest bands of all time
we're now going to do a la single
called oh well
[Music]
tonight the 73 year old is being
remembered as one of the best and most
influential blues guitarists of his
generation
born in london greene was a
singer-songwriter in the band's early
days but his career was cut short by
mental illness
he left fleetwood mac in 1971 and was
later inducted into the rock and roll
hall of fame
along with his seven former band mates
in a statement green's family says he
died peacefully
in his sleep
[Music]
well the doctor isn't in coming up a
canadian chief of medicine
drops out of the nfl
and university classrooms may be closed
this fall but what does that mean for
tuition fees
the answer next
welcome back there's a growing online
petition to reduce
university tuition fees across canada
for the for the fall semester
some schools are raising costs despite
shifting most
classes online during the pandemic and
as alicia drost reports some students
are giving those tuition fees
a failing grade there's no road map for
how to provide
higher education during a pandemic so
schools are following advice from public
health officials and limiting group
gatherings
meaning most classes will be taking
place online this fall
but students are raising some concerns
when the pandemic first hit in march
universities scrambled to complete the
last few weeks of the semester online
a lot of the in-depth learning that
could have been done
didn't get to be fully fleshed out
it's why students are calling for
reduced tuition but many universities
are going the opposite direction
from up three percent at universities in
nova scotia to a near four percent
increase at the university of winnipeg
and an additional seven percent for new
students at the university of calgary
fourth year saint mary's university
student michaela dickens says it's
unfair to students
we're getting less of an education in
our opinion for
more costs she studies anthropology and
much of her education is enhanced by
hands-on experiences
in order to really study the course
itself you actually have to be
physically there to see the bones or
if you're doing landscape archaeology
you kind of need to be
there and doing using the equipment to
know what you're doing
but universities are defending tuition
increases in many cases they say the
increase is part of multi-year
agreements
in universities canada which represents
universities across the country
says switching to online doesn't mean
the cost of offering programs has
decreased
in some cases it costs more it's not
just simply transferring content
online it's redesigning the courses
thinking about new forms of pedagogy
thinking about new tools and new
resources that are available
to bring into the online experience to
help students
universities and governments are
increasing the availability of financial
aid
but still many students say online is
not what they signed up for
and already in quebec some students are
seeking permission to file a class
action lawsuit calling for a partial
refund of last semester's tuition
alicia drafts global news halifax
still ahead lebanon's urgent crisis as a
perfect storm
piles onto the country
[Music]
you're watching global national
welcome back another covid19 vaccine
candidate is entering human trials
the all india institute of medical
sciences in new delhi
administered the first dose on friday
the candidate vaccine is called covaxen
nearly two dozen potential vaccines are
now in various stages of human testing
worldwide
india has recorded more than 1.3 million
confirmed cases of the new coronavirus
that's the third highest in the world
lebanon meanwhile is grappling with its
worst economic crisis in modern history
it's pushed tens of thousands of people
into poverty and triggered the largest
anti-government protests in more than a
decade high inflation and unemployment
shortages of food and medicine are just
some of the problems affecting
millions and as redmond shannon reports
there's no solution
in sight lebanon has seen plenty of
hardship
over the years from its own civil war to
the more
recent influx of refugees from syria
now the country is on its knees again
at least one man appeared to have had
enough protesters
blaming his suicide on desperation
poverty
and hunger the economic and political
crisis
ramped up last fall with protests
triggered by proposed
new taxes and then came kobit 19
suddenly tipping the economy over the
edge so the people that used to be
let's say middle class now they don't
exist anymore
middle class has disappeared because
everyone needs help
lebanon imports almost everything but
the value of its currency has
effectively dropped to one
sixth of its official value banks are
limiting withdrawals
stores have nothing to sell hospitals
are
rationing treatments over 40
50 percent of people unable to access
food water drinkable water
we are in debt just to buy bread eggs
and cheese
says this woman with money almost
worthless
some people are bartering for food on
facebook groups
protesters blame incompetence and
corruption
demanding a total overhaul to lebanon's
unique form of government
a system that means it is always being
torn between regional and
global powers namely iran saudi arabia
and the west there is no easy solution
to this
that does not require turning a blind
eye to bolstering elements of lebanese
society that have been part
of the problem there is no international
will at all from any side
in order to allow the people to manifest
their will to overhaul that system
a bailout from the international
monetary fund has been stalled
too with disagreements over the scale of
the funds needed
and the terms of the loan and new heavy
sanctions
imposed on neighboring syria by the u.s
could stifle a source of funds for
lebanon
albeit iranian money funneled to one of
lebanon's main powers
the political and militant group
hezbollah
and that's why the caesar act is so uh
crippling for lebanon
not because it would provide a solution
but because if you can
implement damage limitation the caesarek
prevents you even from doing that
a perfect storm of history politics and
a pandemic
that's leaving lebanon bereft of
solutions redmond shannon double news
london still ahead birthday protest
honoring a boxer's legacy while
unwrapping a dark
chapter of halifax history
well take a look at this a powerful
moment during last night's delayed
season opener between the blue jays and
tampa bay rays
four toronto players took a knee during
the u.s national anthem
in solidarity with the black lives
matter movement to shine a major league
spotlight
on racial injustice
and a mural of canadian world boxing
champion george dixon was unveiled at
the site of akfrickville in halifax
africville was built by black settlers
back in the 1800s but was demolished by
the city in the 1960s for industrial
development
well today dozens joined a peaceful
protest on what would have been the
boxer's 150th birthday
fighting to preserve his legacy and
honor the site
canada's super bowl champion and the
nfl's first ever practicing
doctor has decided to opt out of the
upcoming season
lauren duvernay tardif says he won't
suit up because of covid19 concerns
the right guard for the kansas city
chiefs is already working on the front
lines of the pandemic in montreal
swapping shoulder pads for scrubs and is
the first nfl player to sideline himself
from the upcoming season
he says despite all the stringent
protocols quote some risks
will remain and that is global national
for this saturday i'm jeff semple
tonight's your canada is black strap
lake
near saskatoon we'd love to see your
canada so please send us your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching
we'll see you back here again tomorrow
have a great night
you